[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous dans 16
autres cas dit ce matin régine bellay
secrétaire départementale adjointe du
snuipp fsu de martinique bonjour
mangeant de ses cadres et j'ai bon jour
aux auditeurs de martinique alors ré le
snuipp c'est le syndicat national
unitaire des instituteurs et professeurs
des écoles et pg ses professeurs de
collèges syndicats enseignants donc
d'enseignants affiliés à la fédération
syndicale unitaire la fs eu alors régine
délais vous êtes venu nous parler alors
jimmy damas il faisait allusion là il ya
quelques minutes
en donnant un communiqué concernant des
écoles il y à grève il ya bien grève ce
jeudi matin dans une partie du monde de
l'éducation
il y avait un préavis depuis plusieurs
jours c'est ça et donc la grève c'est
dès ce jeudi 15 avril voilà donc nos
avons adressé un préavis de grève au
recteur ce qu'il donne le temps de nous
contacter et de nous proposer une
réunion avant le jour prévu d'en rire
avant l'échéance des des cinq jours ce
que vous avez eu ce que nous avons nous
avons obtenu ce
ce rendez-vous effectivement pour cet
après midi voilà mai
la colère est là et l'obtention de ce
rendez vous ne vous a pas dissuadés de
renoncer à l'appel à la grève
il ya une vraie colère il ya une vraie
colère et à lundi et mardi des collègues
qui ont été dans des situations
difficiles il fallait non seulement
gérer les enseignants qui n'était pas
présent pour diverses raisons
d'ailleurs il s'agit pas de dire que
c'était une 70 il y avait diverses
raisons notamment le fait que les
collèges étaient fermées donc pas
d'accueil de son propre enfant
on a trop tendance à oublier que notre
lancée en bout du temps avancée par
oublier que nous sommes également
parents d'élèves mais certains
si on voudrait nous faire fonctionner
comme des bons soldats de l'éducation
nationale nous sommes aussi par an
effectivement lorsque des établissements
sont fermés
eh bien vous savez aussi que nous sommes
très souvent des parents des familles
monoparentales que ce soit voilà et donc
il faut bien qu'on s'en occupe
donc il fallait faire face voilà et puis
ya beau il ya eu beaucoup
d'incompréhension de la part de nos
collègues qu'il n'y ait pas eu
d'aménagement ni même de deux
propositions d'un aménagement pour le
premier degré lors du premier
confinement il nous a été possible de
d'organiser les journées on nous a
demandé de faire plusieurs propositions
des les étudier là c'était non non vous
n'êtes pas concerné mais attendez c'est
pas c'est pas possible on peut pas nous
dire aujourd'hui que nous sommes pas
consultés alors qu'avant les vacances
nous savons bien qu'avec des cars
comprenez ça donc c'était vraiment fermé
la porte
alors nous eh oui mais nous sommes jeudi
il ya eu quand même deux jours deux dans
le premier degré il ya eu deux jours de
d'école au moins lundi et mardi
nous sommes jeudi avec des cas qui sont
remontés avec le collège est fermé
les collèges alors c'est un ou deux
collèges fermés et lycées fermés et non
ça c'est au bout de deux jours on a dit
on a déjà des cas comptes atteint dans
les écoles au bout de deux jours docteur
d'école alors c'est pour ça que sur le
motif de cette grève
vous y allez quand même avec une
certaine dramaturgie ou au snuipp fsu y
compris à l'antenne de martinique
puisque vous évoquez faire grève contre
la mise en danger d'autrui délibéré vous
n'y allez pas de main morte
n'y allons pas demain menthe parce que
nous savons très bien et là vous visé
directement les services académiques et
pas que les services académiques que
soit leur état n'a pas été tout seul à
prendre cette décision là on va pas le
dire que c'est lui il ne l'a bien dit
c'est une décision commune avec le
préfet la rs7 linéaire si nous sommes
contre lyn et ainsi nous avons trimé
suivi ce qui s'est passé au niveau
national et quand lorsque le monde
entier on affirmera que vraiment si ça
devient
vraiment vraiment vraiment indispensable
non il ya eu des situations vraiment
très grave au niveau national et nous ne
voulons pas atteindre ce niveau là au
poignet pasdarans c'est papa de
remplacement au niveau national
forcément ça dégrade la situation du
protocole sanitaire on dit par de
brassage donc ça veut dire que très
rapidement on serait arrivé à cette
situation là sans donner de moyens
d'action aux collègues et donc il
fallait appuyer très tôt sur la
pour dire non on va pas pouvoir y aller
comme ça parce qu'on sait que ça va se
dégrader et on n'aura plus les moyens de
réagir on sera engouffrés dans le
système
et puis voilà il sera difficile d'en
sortir donc vous maintenez qu'il y à une
mise en danger ou une forme de mise en
danger d'autrui délibéré on dit des
libérés parce que il ya des personnels
quand vous dites vous fonctionner
normalement
il ya des personnels fragile je
n'entends pas dire je n'entends pas
parler des personnes fragiles des
personnels vulnérables quand on dit
aussi la première raison c'est la crise
sanitaire c'est l'état de qui ça n'était
mais pas bon non
on n'entend pas pour vous alors de ce
point de vue comment se passe
l'organisation au niveau de la campagne
de vaccination concernant les
enseignants chez nous quel regard vous
posez vous de votre point de vue
syndical
au snuipp fsu alors au snuipp fsu nous
avons souhaité que les que tous les
personnels qui le souhaitaient puissent
avoir accès au vaccin puisque vous êtes
plutôt nombreux à ne pas vous être une
des solutions pour peut-être assez dit
et nous sommes en voie quand même avant
d'être méfiants vis-à-vis des vaccins
pour autant tous ceux qui le souhaitent
nous n'allons pas nous y opposer tous
ceux qui ceux qui le souhaitent babala
leur donner la possibilité de
recommander pas particulièrement
non nous n'en sommes pas là pour nous ne
pourrons pas prendre position pour dire
nous sommes contents nous sommes pour
nous sommes pour le fait que les
collègues qui le souhaitent puissent
avoir accès au vaccin il y en a qui le
souhaitent en a qui ne souhaite pas que
ce soir et exhorté l'ue à être facilitée
peut-être d'une certaine manière à ce
moment là à ce moment là c'est ça c'est
ça la campagne
vous évoquez également globalement un
manque de transparence quand même de la
part du rectorat
oui pourquoi qu'est ce que vous voulez
dire que ça leur personnel aux sauteurs
scène transparence avant les vacances
avant la sortie là il y avait des cas
qui remontait à qui on savait parmi les
collégiens les lycéens qu'il y avait des
dégâts et nous recevions des appels
pendant dire mais c'est pas possible
qu'on n'en parle pas et c'est pour ça
que que nous savons qu'il ya eu des cas
qui ne sont pas remontés parce que mais
on n'en parlait pas le pain ou à
l'étouffée un peu alors vous faites pas
alors est ce que c'est parce que on ne
donne plus d'information parce que vous
savez va là bas il faut écarter les
ordonner les syndicats voilà donc on se
débrouille on gère et ils seront
informés après non c'est que même si
vous ne fermez pas les syndicats à
l'attention de la communauté scolaire et
des personnels pouvait dire voilà on
note que kylie a des cas qui remontre à
redoubler d'efforts bon voilà on peut
informer les personnels et les parents
qui voient que leurs enfants sont
malades parce que
lorsqu'il ya des cas au collège au
collège de fort de france il ya des
fratries à des enfants au collège qui
ont des frais sur en élémentaire et les
enfants ils arrivent ils sont malades on
sait pas pourquoi
le fait d'avoir mis le système de 2000
classe au collège et lycéens enfin pour
les collégiens lycéens c'est quand même
une mesure en soi c'est déjà une prise
en compte un petit peu de la situation
en fin jeudi un petit peu voire même
quand même largement c'est une prise en
compte pour les élèves demi glace ou de
me jauger déneigeuse ans et des micros
un jour sur deux ou alors c'est en gros
c'est ça
voilà c'est une organisation qui permet
d'alterner les jours de présence et le
jour de distance ça ça vous à grenoux ce
pôle
mais oui mais nous nous a pas donné la
possibilité de long même de l'envisager
c'était on n'a pas même pas eu à se
positionner là dessus
c'était vous fonctionner normalement
alors normalement en cas de crise voilà
qu'est ce qui est normal en en cadettes
raison en situation normale en cas de
crise
non tu veux pas y avoir de
fonctionnement normal il faut que sa
mort est apte et en même temps vous ne
préconise est pas non plus la fermeture
des écoles
non parce qu'on ne sait pas à comprendre
donc non non vous ne savez pas ça nous
savons très bien qu'il faut un contact
on est dans un métier où il faut
entendre il faut voir il faut expliquer
on ne peut pas dire voilà pas de
contacts d'accord maintenant on le
répète et nous a été possible de
d'étudier la possibilité de fonctionner
d'une certaine manière d'aménager le
temps que ce soit que cela ne soit
donnée on est on nous a demandé de
réfléchir à ce que vous demandez c'est
plus de concertation a juste de
d'associations de partenariat pour une
meilleure organisation exaltation notre
notamment dans le premier degré
notamment dans le premier degré puisque
le second degré lui a pu s'organiser
rapidement en deux minutes
régine bellay secrétaire départementale
adjointe du snuipp fsu martinique est ce
qu'il ya de la souffrance au travail
parmi les personnels enseignants
souffrance au travail du
particulièrement évidemment à cette
gestion de crise il ya beaucoup
d'angoissé monsieur k ruche
oui il ya la souffrance au travail il ya
beaucoup d'angoissé les personnels ont
peur notamment tous ceux qui sont
appelés à remplacer souvent quand vous
allez en remplacement vous allez en
remplacement parce qu'il ya eu des cas
covit donc forcément il y à de
l'angoissé il ya beaucoup d'angoissé et
ce sentiment de malades de ne pas être
pris en compte
oui ça pèse ça pèse dans la motivation
ça pèse dans dans le ce qu'on fait au
quotidien
oui il ya de la souffrance au travail à
ce niveau là dernière question la
fameuse continuité pédagogique notamment
avec les nouveaux outils enfin les
nouveaux ils sont pas si nouveau que ça
mais enfin voilà on les utilise
plus largement cette fameuse continuité
pédagogique où en est on est ce que ça
fonctionne bien pour maintenir le lien
scolaire à vos yeux
à nos yeux ça ne fonctionne pas encore
bien puisque on n'a même pas eu à se
positionner là-dessus voit comment
s'organiser on fera comme on a
l'habitude de faire on va et on va se
débrouiller
même si c'est parce que nous souhaitons
nous ce temps pouvoir être efficace dans
cette continuité pédagogique et
puisqu'elle ne prend pas forcément la
forme de
de connexion internet a peut être autre
chose qu'un jour vous avez dit papy
exemple le papier le papier est toujours
possible on peut travailler à distance
ont pour remettre un fichier des 10600
par correspondance venir m ou alors une
fois qu'on a qu'on a ces exercices
pouvoir avoir un contact téléphonique
vous dis voilà moi j'ai compris là j'ai
par contre il ya une fracture comme vous
avez quand même dans les eaux calmes
nous sommes partiellement connectés ou
alors défendent avant une connexion
aller à bas débit elle ne va pas juste
partout dans le nom l'abeille n'ont pas
les mêmes conditions les mêmes facilités
que ça pose problème qu'on peut pas dire
oui ça ira pour tout le monde ça n'ira
pas pour tout le monde là aussi il
faudra adapter
merci régime ben ali d'avoir répondu à
nos questions ce matin et puis donc
c'est confirmé il ya un appel à la grève
pour ce jeudi
en tout cas l'appel de votre syndicat le
snuipp fsu martinique aussi bien premier
que second degré non aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est le premier le premier
degré qui a souhaité marquer locaux et
dire que il faudra compter avec nous
pour par la suite également bonne
journée pour retrouver jimmy merci à
vous